laney wilson you have so many awards
tonight that i have to carry one of them
for you how you feeling i am um on cloud
nine i just like i feel like
everything is just starting to come to
fruition and i just feel so supported by
nashville by the fans i feel
like
just i can't even hardly explain it is
it emotional to hold these in your hand
it is and somebody asked me earlier they
said where are you gonna put that thing
i said i'm gonna put it on my mantel
next to my dog pudding
so
i got three of them tonight you've got
three of them and like i told you
earlier many more to come on your
journey what does what kind of doors do
you think are going to open now with
these three awards um you know i feel
like just even being nominated
opens doors but much less actually
taking two home
it's just gonna give first of all me
that extra confidence to just keep on
going to keep on writing what i know to
keep on being me and um i think it is
literally gonna bust some doors down i'm
ready and you're taking three of them
home girl you said two you got three i
got three come on now three so how are
you gonna celebrate these three
uh we have so much celebrating to do my
parents are in town from louisiana and i
know they were super emotional and just
so proud so the whole team is getting
together tonight and some drinks will be
involved
we're going to be not feeling good
tomorrow but that's okay we're feeling
good tonight
how much fun have you had out there at
the acm so much fun this is my very
first acms i said i wasn't going to come
until i had a reason to be here
here we are goodness congratulations
triplets